[Music]
we all love a good story about the
underdog rising up and defeating the bad
guy there are a lot of these throughout
history but while some are tales of
triumph others are tales of caution and
demise
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives four
experts share stories of fights that
were won by the underdog and a few
others that are only remembered for
their colossal failure
we begin now in the late middle ages
with a battle between french knights and
flemish peasants
[Music]
the two armies were roughly equal in
total number of men
but the french forces were all
professional soldiers and included
thousands of mounted men
versus the flemish who were
overwhelmingly amateurs and were almost
all on foot
to a medieval observer the sides would
have seemed hopelessly mismatched in
that one category that was most valued
on battlefields knights
the flemish army was drawn up with their
backs to the walls of cortrae and a
nearby river
and there was a large field between them
and the french army
the selection of this site to make their
stand was a clever one
because like much of the flemish
countryside that intervening field was
low-lying wet land which was
traversed by a number of streams and
water channels
such terrain was not well suited to
charging horsemen
on the other hand they had backed
themselves into a position from which
there could be no retreat
they simply had to win or they would all
be killed
and the fight began with the french
crossbowmen unleashing a reign of bolts
the flemish crossbowmen who were
stationed in front of the main line
replied with shots of their own and a
duel of missiles ensued
the french were more numerous and were
also supported by infantry so they drove
back the flemish crossbowman who then
took shelter behind the main line
the french crossbowmen and foot soldiers
were eager to press their advantage and
they might have done so to good effect
but robert fearing that they might
defeat the flemish on their own ordered
them
back to make way for his knights
the battalions of aristocratic knights
ponderously began to move forward
but they couldn't build momentum on the
swampy ground
then when they had to cross those little
streams it brought their advance to a
standstill
after
awkwardly picking their way across they
continued on towards the flemish line
which bristled with lowered pikes on the
right and left sides the flemish line
managed to
blunt the onslaught
but in the center french knights cut
their way into the flemish formation and
threatened to break through
seeing this the commander of the flemish
reserves brought up his troops to
bolster the line
knots of pike and who dedocked
brandishing militia clustered around
each night hacking and poking until he
fell from the saddle and then pounding
on the fallen man until finally someone
managed to insert a blade or a point
into a weak spot in the armor
after three hours of intense combat the
battle was finally winding down
it was an utter disaster for the french
thousands of france's best warriors lay
dead on the bloody field
among them were 75 high lords and around
twelve hundred nights
in the aftermath of the battle the
golden spurs worn by 500 of these nights
were collected together and mounted on
the walls of a nearby church
and it's because of this that the battle
has sometimes popularly become known as
the battle of the golden spurs
the battle of portray halted french
attempts to seize the region and it made
possible the eventual creation of the
netherlands and belgium as independent
states
at san antonio santa ana fought the
battle of the alamo
a few months earlier the texas rebels
had ejected a mexican garrison there and
this was an insult he meant to redress
the old half ruined mission church of
san antonio de valero better known as
the alamo
was the american strong point but it was
not easy to defend
it would have needed about a thousand
men in view of its crumbling walls and
large perimeter but was actually
garrisoned by only about 150 with a few
women and children some cattle and corn
and a fierce determination not to
retreat
the leaders of the rebels were william
travis and jim bowie
houston had actually ordered travis and
his men to abandon the alamo and destroy
it rightly foreseeing that it was
indefensible and that the men would be
of more use in swelling the ranks of his
army
travis had ignored the order in a series
of defiant letters that closed with the
valediction victory or death
most of the men inside the alamo with
him were recent arrivals in texas
including bowie a slave trader smuggler
and notorious knife fighter
and the half legendary frontiersman
davey crockett
crockett had until recently been a whig
congressman from
tennessee inevitably after a 13 day
siege santa anna's force overwhelmed the
defenders and killed the survivors
possibly including davy crockett
while suffering 600 casualties in the
process
meanwhile another mexican general jose
de urrea
was marching a second force along the
coast where his troops defeated a texan
force in the town of goliath
just as santa ana had killed all the men
at the alamo so urea massacred 371
prisoners of war further poisoning
relations between mexicans and the
texans
for a month houston continued to retreat
and santa anna to advance
more men shocked by the mexicans
brutality at the alamo and goliath
joined his force
finally on april 21 1836 he turned and
fought at san jacinto despite being
outnumbered his 800 men shouting
remember the alamo surprised the mexican
force of about 1500 men
by advancing in mid-afternoon
this was the siesta hour
according to legend santa anna himself
was enjoying himself with his mistress a
mixed race woman known as the yellow
rose of texas in a luxurious tent
some versions of the story say that she
was loyal to the americans and had
deliberately set about distracting him
at the crucial moment
the fighting lasted barely half an hour
after which the victorious texans
responded to recent mexican atrocities
by slaughtering hundreds of their
prisoners of war
santa ana himself fled the battlefield
shedding his elaborate uniform on route
but he was picked up early the next day
and brought back to face sam houston
houston himself had been shot in the
ankle lost a lot of blood and was in
intense pain
otherwise the americans lost only nine
men killed
many of his soldiers wanted houston to
kill santa anna there and then
houston however had the good sense to
realize that this was a symbolically
important moment that he was dealing
with a head of state
and that the eyes of the world were upon
him
he saw the greater benefits of showing
that he was civilized rather than
vindictive
he therefore spared santa anna's life
and compelled him to sign the treaty of
velasco ending the war acknowledging
texas as an independent state
and setting its southern boundary at the
rio grande
the newly independent texans are once
convened a congress to affirm the
legality of slavery
it's one of the great embarrassments of
texas history that theirs was a
revolution undertaken in part
to ensure the continuation of slavery in
an area that had recently abolished it
and so at 12 noon on easter monday 1916
about 1500 irish rebels took to the
streets of dublin and seized multiple
sites within the city center and held
them by force of arms the easter rising
had begun
the 1500 dublin rebels on that easter
monday occupied a number of buildings
and sites throughout central dublin
one key area included saint stephen's
green on the south side in the heart of
georgia and dublin here some of the
fiercest direct fighting occurred
another was bowlin's mill on the grand
canal here eamon de valera was the
commander and the position was so secure
that it actually saw little fighting and
surrendered with great reluctance
jacob's biscuit factory and the south
dublin union on the south side were
areas of major fighting
most significant of all was the general
post office just across the o'connell
street bridge on the north side of the
liffey
here james connolly and patrick purse
were headquartered and it was on the
steps of the gpo that purse read the
proclamation of the irish republic at
the start of the rising
with the new orange white and green
tri-color flag of the irish nation
flying above the gpo purse read the
stirring opening lines
irishmen and irish women in the name of
god and of the dead generations from
which she receives her old tradition of
nationhood
ireland through us
summons her children to her flag and
strikes for her freedom
this proclamation was to have a massive
influence in the years to come not least
during the irish civil war when die-hard
republicans viewed any compromise of
full independence as a sellout of the
heroic martyrs who proclaimed the
republic in 1916.
if the rebels truly believed the
citizenry of ireland would rise up and
join them they were sorely disappointed
only a handful of sporadic actions
occurred in the countryside
in the city of dublin citizens at first
thought this was another drill by the
volunteers and when they realized it was
a rebellion in earnest many were more
annoyed than inspired
then when the killing and the
destruction of the city reached its peak
many were outraged and condemning of the
rebels and when purse finally
surrendered at the gpo on saturday and
the rebels were led away to prison some
in the jeering dublin crowd spat at them
the failure of the rebel strategy was
essentially one of numbers only
one-third of the dublin force turned out
and the plan of holding multiple sites
throughout the city depended on
communication and swift reinforcement
that was simply impossible given the
paucity of rebel soldiers
it was easy for the british army to
isolate and neutralize each location
but the army response was excessive and
took little notice of the difference
between civilian and revel
there were many innocent casualties
including francis sheehy skeffington a
well-known and highly regarded pacifist
and friend of the writer james joyce who
was arrested while trying to prevent
citizens from looting irish businesses
then shot and killed by an apparently
insane british officer
general john maxwell was the commander
of the british forces in dublin and he
declared martial law and responded with
brutal suppression
over the next 12 days he thereby
proceeded to execute by firing squad 15
of the most prominent leaders of the
rising starting with purse thomas
mcdonough and thomas clark who were shot
at kilmainham jail
in the days that followed purse's
younger brother willie john mcbride
former husband of mod gun and joseph
plunkett were among the executed
with each execution and the revealing of
the rebels poems and letters and the
clear understanding that these were not
german pawns or selfish criminals the
public sympathy for the rebels grew and
grew
soon international outrage was voiced
over the executions which were quickly
transforming the leaders into martyrs
asquith hurried to dublin and halted the
killings but too late to save connolly
de valera and thomas ashe were spared as
was one of the several women leaders the
countess markowitz who had been active
in the fighting at stevens green
but the irreparable damage had been done
the british response had turned the
rebels into martyrs and turned what
might have been almost a farce into a
stirring sacrifice of heroism for
ireland
revolution involves a delicate balancing
act
revolutionary vanguards require popular
support while at the same time they must
harness and guide their followers energy
and passions
additionally
popular movements fail without
leadership
spokespersons and an ideological plan
passions aroused can create disruption
but revolutionary leaders are needed to
articulate a common strategy and advance
an agenda
take for example the occupy wall street
protest in the united states after the
financial markets crisis and the
following recession of
and
2008-2009
in september 2011
a group of protesters
gathered at manhattan's zuccotti park
to condemn the inequity in economic
power that divided the world
into the fabulously wealthy one percent
and the 99 percent to which everyone
else belonged
in rejecting top-down structures and the
control of the many by the few
the movement issued leadership
and became a laboratory for
participatory democracy
according to the washington post
this message
resonated across the country and across
the world
but the protesters lacked leadership and
concrete plans for action
it was an uprising
not a revolution
and so
occupy wall street eventually fizzled
occupy wall street didn't dismantle
american capitalism
nor the u.s political system
but it did attract the media and
national attention and it became a
social phenomenon
of course
attracting media attention is part and
parcel of any successful revolutionary
movement
successful revolutions require mass
support
the message needs to go viral
this aspect of revolution predates
twitter and facebook by a few hundred
years
before the american colonies declared
independence from britain
revolutionary journalists and
pamphleters such as thomas payne and
samuel adams
first had to convince other colonists of
the wisdom and righteousness of the
independence cause
it's no small task to transform the
world
a nation
or even a political system
and it's never quick
although revolutions are typically
commemorated on a specific date
they tend to be long-running disruptions
that snake through several stages
and can extend over many years
this points up the fact that national
independence days
and other commemorative dates
tend to be both highly selective and
subjective
stated otherwise
how a revolution is remembered
can vary tremendously over time
indeed
the ways in which individuals groups and
states remember
and commemorate a revolution
tell us as much about the present
political situation
as it does about the past
a revolution
might be a triumph or tragedy
a success or horrible failure
some revolutionaries are heroes
others are villains traitors and
terrorists
we must acknowledge
not only the winners
but also the losers who fall along the
way
when we do
revolution becomes more than a
caricature
it becomes more than a symbol
it becomes more than a singular moment
that is celebrated annually
it becomes part of history
and an essential element of the human
experience
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream don't forget to subscribe
to this youtube channel for new episodes
of perspectives and you can watch
previous ones here